[Musique]
lorsque j'ai le privilège de créer un
spectacle au cirque du soleil de quelque
chose qui m'inspire beaucoup
c'est le fait que la troupe est née de
la rue il a été fondé dans les années 80
par des amuseurs publics et
s'influencent la façon dont on crée des
spectacles
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui de
quelque chose qui me passionne le
processus de création du cirque du
soleil j'espère que ça va vous inspirer
dans vos différentes sphères d'activités
la première chose qu'un amuseur public
fait avant même de commencer son
spectacle c'est ceci
[Musique]
oh
ce cercle indique au public qu'il ya
deux réalités
la réalité de tous les jours et l'autre
réalité celle de tous les possibles à
l'intérieur de ce siècle les règles
habituelles ne s'applique plus on peut
tout faire
et on peut être différent en fait et on
doit être différent parce qu'il faut
capter l'attention du public qui
marchent dans la rue par quelque chose
de viscéral quelque chose de personnel
quelque chose d'inusité afin qu'ils
changent leur trajectoire et qui
viennent devant vous et qui devient de
votre public
le street performance est la seule forme
de spectacles durant laquelle a au cours
de laquelle le public va payer mais
après la représentation
et ça change tout le processus de
création au cirque du soleil est
semblable à ce cercle
il crie en espace de tous les possibles
mais c'est un espace exigeant où chacun
doit se dépasser
et chacun va prendre un risque comme un
acrobate
mais il n'est pas seul puisque ce cercle
est un cercle de la collaboration
je ne suis jamais de powerpoint mais
ceci c'est l'ancêtre du powerpoint et
comme un amuseur public
il garde un contact visuel constants
avec les spectateurs et ils en écoute
les moindres réactions
mais
le cercle est omniprésent dans la
réalité du cirque
la plupart de nos scènes ont cette forme
circulaire cirque vient du moose cercle
la première chose qu'on fait lorsqu'on
arrive dans une nouvelle ville on trace
un cercle au sol pour y monter notre
chapiteau
dans chacun des dix neuf spectacles
partout sur la planète et a toujours
près du backstage
ce cercle rouge héros on l'appelle notre
tapis rouge c'est là où au moins une
fois par semaine
toute la troupe se rassemblent et là où
on donne les bonnes nouvelles les
mauvaises nouvelles
où on se dit nos quatre vérités dans le
blanc des yeux devant le siège social du
cirque ya cette spirale végétal qui
représente le processus de création de
nos spectacles ou surtout soleil et je
vous en parlais encore un peu plus dans
une minute
mais avant je vais vous montrer quelque
chose que j'aime beaucoup c'est comment
on monte un chapiteau
[Musique]
les éclaireurs we have returned to buy
in the text is coming to
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est
m
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
two three four 2 3% c'est un cri de
ralliement qui trouve son écho partout
dans le processus de création est
partout dans l'entreprise
ici le défi est de taille cette attitude
devient complètement indispensable au
siège social
pour chaque spectacle on a un lieu qui
lui réserver une salle de création toute
spéciale et c'est réservé pendant toute
la durée de la création ça peut être
deux en deux ans et demi
si la petite caverne où on va rêver le
spectacle quand j'ai commencé à
travailler sur mon premier spectacle de
tournée
curieuse cabinet des curiosités j'ai
demandé tout de suite avoir la salle et
je suis allée avec ma collègue chantal
tremblay la directrice de création
on a ouvert la porte et tout de suite
j'ai fait il ya un problème on me dit
quoi payer la table quoi la table la
table rectangulaire sans aucun sens
c'est comme une table de conseil
d'administration moi je vais me tenir
coi au bout puis je vais parler les gens
m'ont m'écouter respectueusement non ça
n'a pas de sens on peut pas travailler
comme ça ça prendrait une table qui
permettent un rapport plus égalitaire
entre les gens quelque chose qui nous
permette vraiment de faire de l'art
et là je me suis souvenu d'une table
ronde mythique qui était utilisé par la
première équipe de création au cirque du
soleil
j'ai demandé il faut trouver cette table
a fait aller partout il faut faire tout
ce qu'il faut et de semaine sont venus
michel on est allé partout on est allé
dans les sous sols les entrepôts à anjou
les entrepôts à saint-michel et ceci
c'est un peu la distance entre un jouet
saint michel
et on n'a pas trouvé la table alors j'ai
dit bon ok ce qu'on devrait faire ses
dépenses et nos premiers dollars sur la
confection de notre table ronde et ça a
tout changé
en fait j'aime tellement cette table que
je les apporte est avec moi à cannes
pour vous alors je vous demanderais de
bien vouloir accueillir directement des
studios de création du cirque du soleil
à montréal mesdames et messieurs la
table de création merci avec les studios
d'entraînement avec les salles de
répétition et la scène pour moi la table
de création c'est véritablement le
paradis sur terre c'est là où on a le
privilège de se rassembler et de créer
des mondes du monde meilleur des mondes
nouveaux autour de cette table il ya
tout le monde c'est pas le rapport
metteur en scène qui rencontre le
scénographe ensuite metteur en scène qui
rencontre le concepteur de coques
souvenons aussi tout le monde est invité
à la table en même temps donc il ya le
scénographe le concepteur d'éclairages
concepteur des costumes conceptrice des
maquillages concepteur des appareils
acrobatique du mouvement acrobatique la
directrice de production
la directrice de création le compositeur
donc on était si serré et tout ce
monde-là se rassemblent pendant des
semaines et des mois pour rêver au
spectacle en fait je pourrais vous en
parler pendant des heures mais pour mais
d'être un peu plus concis je vais faire
appel à la musique
parce que le processus de création du
cirque et quelque chose d'intérieur et
qui commence comme une danse tout
doucement et qui vous prend par lui
ça commence au début par le metteur en
scène qui arrive avec l'idée d'un thème
du spectacle salut vient du gué créative
du cirque jean françois bouchard ou de
lui-même
donc moi quand je serai la mise en scène
je propose cette idée je propose ce
terme est tout de suite tout le monde
réagit de façon émotive et tout le monde
va va dire ben moi ça m'inspire ceci ça
m'inspire cela on va parler des défis
créatifs qu'on a envie de se lancer
au sortir de nos propres sentiers battus
et ensuite tout le monde apporte des
sources d'inspiration donc ça fait le
dessin d'une fleur qui pousse
courageusement au milieu du désert ça
peut être une collection photo sépia
parce qu'on aime la couleur sépia
sap est un extrait de poème ça peut être
l'extrait d'un film qui vous a marqué
des souvenirs de notre enfance un objet
qui vient de chez soi
et pendant toutes ces semaines à ce
maelström commencent à s'accumuler
c'est la spirale de création dans toute
sa largeur
tout est ouvert c'est un processus
organique ça n'a pas besoin d'être
logique il faut que ça nous parle à tous
il ya des choses qu'on évacue après
quelques journées des nouvelles idées
qui arrivent et cette spirale est
toujours en mouvement
ce qu'on suit ses pas une recette c'est
pas un plan c'est notre intuition c'est
beaucoup plus difficile parce qu'il faut
créer cent fidèles
au bout de quelques semaines le mettant
en scène propose le début d'une histoire
ce sera un lien dramaturge et qui va
relier tous les numéros acrobatiques et
la substance et théâtrale du spectacle
tout le monde va discuter il ya des
portions d'histoire qu'on va abandonner
donc qu'ils vont être générés par cette
discussion et la salle de création
commence à se tapissent et du storyboard
des numéros acrobatiques les
illustrations des costumes
le scénographe à dire avec sa maquette
préliminaire pour le décor ça donne des
nouvelles idées aux concepteurs
d'éclairage à la conceptrice des
maquillages et pendant tout ce temps le
contrôleur technique
les freins d'eilat
ensuite arrive un moment
des artistes y a rien de plus beau quand
ils viennent des quatre coins de la
planète
ça fait des mois que vous écrivez ce
personnage et qui vous arrive et qui
disent bonjour je m'appelle cas
je serai monsieur microcosmos briec iam
anthony la haine à will be mini le
spectacle ces cas
le cercle la création s'ouvre pour
accueillir tous ces rêves des artistes
des coachs acrobatiques les coaches
artistique
les chorégraphes on commence à monter
les numéros le cercle s'agrandit la
spirale ce retrait si parce qu'à des
choses qu'on ne peut pas faire les
choses qu'on ne veut pas faire le
spectacle
petit à petit commence à prendre forme
et l'esprit sont des gages comme ça
on commence la mise en place du
spectacle toute la mise en scène des
numéros mais aussi des transitions de
l'ouverture pour changera trois fois de
la finale qu'on trouvera une semaine
avant la première
et justement trois semaines avant la
première on fait quelque chose que je
crois qu'on est pas mal tout seul à
faire aussi qu on ouvre les portes du
chapiteau
alors que le spectacle n'est pas du tout
prêt
c'est une commune petite créature qui
commence à prendre forme
ça demande beaucoup beaucoup de courage
et d'humilité parce qu'on va donner le
spectacle à 200 personnes
les amis des collègues qui sont les
juges les plus intransigeants et c'est
ce qu'on veut on va voir ce qui
fonctionne avec le public ce qui
fonctionne pas ce qu'on doit modifier ou
ce qu'on doit carrément abandonné tout
est fait pour le public
on va après après cette représentation
est il on va procéder à des changements
parfois majeur on va changer l'ordre des
scènes apporter une nouvelle musique un
nouveau costume
parfois un nouvel artiste et on possède
deux fois en deux semaines à cet
exercice difficile
il demande beaucoup de courage mais en
même temps nous permet de vérifier la
force de cet esprit d'équipé qu'on a
créé pendant des mois autour de cette
table est ensuite bien sûr c'est le
moment le choeur ou la spirale s'est
concentrée en un seul point et c'est
effectivement le coeur de ce qu'on fait
c'est la première du spectacle est
quelque chose que je voudrais partager
avec vous avant de quitter cette année
on a créé un spectacle en amérique
latine
basé sur la musique d'un groupe qu'on ne
connaissait pas du tout le groupe
s'appelle sur das thériault et les gens
là bas ils écoutent et le vénère autant
que les beatles ils nous disent tous
on a grandi avec cette musique si on
faisait un film sur ma vie la musique de
soda stéréo en serait assurément la
bande sonore
donc nous avec beaucoup d'humilité on se
dit comment on peut faire pour sentir
cette musique et donner le spectacle au
public la balle
le spectacle qui mérite donc ce qu'on a
fait pour la première fois de notre
histoire
on a agrandi le cercle de la création
pour laisser entrer les spectateurs pour
laisser entrer le public
et comme je vous disais c'est que je
n'avais jamais fait avant donc vous
voyez on a ouvert la porte de la salle
voyait la table ronde ici et par
internet
on a permis aux gens de se brancher à
nous et au départ là on a dit on c'est
pas du tout ils vont être quoi un sens
de st
au bout de cinq secondes de la première
session live
ils étaient huit mille au bout de 15
minutes quelqu'un écrit sur un papier
ils étaient 86 milles
waouh on a demandé des commentaires
après la cession il en est venu 4000 et
à partir de ces commentaires c'étaient
des mots clés des rêves du public j'ai
écrit le début d'une histoire pour ce
tableau
donc on les a conviés à créer un tableau
du spectacle avec nous et chaque mois
pendant un an
on les a rencontrés ils ont fait toutes
les étapes du processus de création
personnage costumes choix du numéro
acrobatique chorégraphies tout ça est la
raison pourquoi je vous présente ici
aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai envie de
laisser rouler c'était vraiment un
un processus qui représente un risque
pour nous on n'avait jamais fait
personne n'avait jamais fait et j'avais
l'impression qu'en prenant ce risque
d'ouverture sur l'autoroute
électroniques ont marché dans les pas
des fondateurs du cirque et on était
comme eux dans la rue et on regardait le
public avec les moyens technologiques
modernes dans le blanc des yeux afin
d'ajuster notre tir de création et
d'être inspirés par leur attention et de
leur donner le spectacle qu'ils méritent
quand on a fait quand on a fait
curieuse pardon ces petits médias c'est
le second spectacle
j'ai demandé qu'on construise une
seconde table ronde est en ce moment en
train de créer deux autres spectacles
donc j'ai demandé qu'on fabrique deux
autres tables rondes les gens me
demandent souvent combien de spectacles
j'aimerais créer c'est sûr que comme
artiste j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire
j'aimerais en faire plusieurs mais
fondamentalement je crois comme vous
tous que ce que je cherche à faire c'est
de créer un maximum de tables rondes où
les gens se rassemblent pour créer de la
beauté
pour d autres les autres êtres humains
la dernière chose qu'un amuseur public
faire avant de quitter son cercle
c'est de remercier son public
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]